first of all I just want to say welcome
to the School of Forestry and
studies on this wet afternoon but more
particularly to this panel discussion
and the Yale book launch of cooperation
2020 transforming business for
tomorrow's world we're delighted also to
have our guests here
Yvonne Schwinn odd and Vincent Stanley
from Patagonia it's great to have you
here and it's very appropriate that
they're here today to join us in this
discussion about the intersection of
public profits and social purpose and
what that means for the future of our
economy
my job here this afternoon is very
simple and very short and that's because
I had the privilege of introducing the
author of corporation 2020 province of
dev Caban is a good friend of this
school he's the founder and CEO of Geist
advisory a consulting firm which helps
governments and corporations discover
measure value and manage their impacts
on natural and human capital pavan spent
much of his early career in the banking
sector and he's advised world leaders on
the green economy and we were hugely
fortunate last year to have her man join
our community as a Dorothy s McCluskey
visiting fellow and he remains with us
this year as a visiting fellow for the
academic year and he's been a great
resource who's reached out to our
students and our community particularly
in the area of the economics of
ecosystems and biodiversity or team so
we have a treat in store for us for the
next hour or so and we're going to hear
more about corporation 2020 we're going
to hear more about Patagonia's
philosophy and it's a huge pleasure to
introduce Pavan
button the technology of the year that
I've been away thanks to ebay with
Stewart anyway
who've been really be organizers for
this and also the hosts for our project
the campaign cooperation 2020 and it is
a campaign delighted to have some people
here ties Lucia my Imam who've been
there campaigning literally a trio so
hard then in fact they had no time for
fun isn't that right
so without much further ado I'd like to
welcome our guest here Yvonne you are so
well-known here that actually need no
introduction
Vincent and Yvonne York York your
products as it were no doubt worn by a
large number of this community of
foresters and environment to people that
we have here and of course by others as
well
Patagonia has been called the coolest
company on the planet by fortune there
was a few years back and you've been
always brutally honest about being
transparent about the footprints of your
products and the impacts of your
business with your customers I level of
integrity
I believe in communications and
advertising and in responsibility
towards the Commons that you that your
products help us research and search and
enjoy I think that level of
responsibility and integrity is rare to
find so I commend both of you for for
having achieved that through Patagonia
the one you founded Patagonia and of
course our a well well-heeled alpinist
and environmentalist of sorts and have
also founded a 1% for the planet scheme
as part of what Patagonia does to
contribute a percent of its annual
revenues to environmental causes
I wish many of the clients and companies
that I speak with in the cooperation
2020 all did that that would make life
different Vincent as the acting VP of
Marketing and as co-author of the book
that the two of you launched here at
Yale in the law school
you've been very much part of the fabric
if I may my pun off of Patagonia
and both of you have actually
demonstrated to me as I will describe in
a few moments many of the principles of
what my team and I here at Yale called
cooperation 2020 I wanted to spend a few
moments just painting the background as
as dean Twain mentioned part of my work
for the last several years has been to
advise government's on the green economy
a green economy as the way forward
towards an economy which achieves human
wellbeing and achieves a wider spread of
benefits and reduce disparities between
the rich and the poor but at the same
time does not create more environmental
risks and even more ecological
scarcities but that kind of green
economy is easier said than done it's
been well proven by the UN reports that
I was privileged to lead which were
published last year it's been well
supported by the toolkit for valuing
nature services that tea brought to the
table but none of this is going to
happen because two-thirds of today's
economy is basically private sector
sixty percent of GDP generated by the
private sector seventy percent of jobs
are in the private sector here in the
u.s. those numbers are more like seventy
five percent and eighty three percent so
we're not going to get anywhere with
hand waving and great vision in terms of
macro direction or even sectoral
direction unless we make change happen
on the ground at the corporation level
and that brings me back to the real
theme of corporation 2020 which is that
today's cooperation is almost hardwired
to generate its best performance in a
brown economy how on earth will its the
total of its contributions add up to a
green economy
tomorrow's corporation needs a new DNA
and that DNA is one which recognizes
corporations social purpose something
that has been there in history after all
corporations were created by kings and
queens and governments in order to
achieve certain purposes be it collect
taxes or or create railways or indeed
conquer countries like India which where
I came from corporations did all of that
and it is rather well but it was with
social purpose howsoever defined and
then it came the 19th century and the
early 20th and during that crucial
period of 1820 to 1920 was born today's
cooperation which is a seeker of profit
an optimizer of value of financial
capital for shareholders but not one
that is concerned about this living
fabric of this planet that is the
natural capital nor concerned about
social capital which it uses nor the
human capital which it deploys of course
there are good exceptions and Patagonia
is one of them but the by and large the
DNA that we have been seen encouraged in
in the economy and around the world is
the DNA of the large multinational an
arbitrage of resources from where it's
cheap to get them often places in Africa
where there are less well governed an
arbitrage of capacity wherever there is
government subsidies to manufacturers
such as Singapore Korea India etc an
arbitrage here of human capital where
it's cheap and available as in China
India Vietnam Cambodia etc and finally
an arbitrage of sales value an arbitrage
er of client markets in Europe in USA
Japan and the rich countries around the
world so this form of arbitrage again
the the ability of the corporation today
to be what it is has been developed
actually through a legal history which
is scarcely 150 years old and through an
economic history which is scarcely 60
years or post-war lasts lastly has seen
the growth of the MNC as the powerhouse
of the global economy in 1970 there were
scarcely 20 corporations of turnover
greater than 25 billion dollars now
there are 350 in 1970 there were less
than 20 corporations whose turnover was
greater than 0.1 percent of global GDP
now there are 120 the bulking up of the
corporation and the MNC has a success
model of today's economy is despite the
fact that we see degradation zin every
other sphere employment is under stress
economic growth is under stress poverty
has not disappeared the environment is
severely stress all aspects of our
existence appear to be stressed except
the success of the corporation I call
this divergence such divergences cannot
carry on forever and the challenge here
is how do we engender the DNA of
cooperation
2020 our responsible corporation whose
goals are aligned with society who works
out these externalities measures them
manages them creates human capital
builds communities and creates social
capital how do we get all this to happen
in good time so that we don't actually
you know drive the super tanker into the
into the storm that we are headed
towards so with this quick background as
to what cooperation 2020 is about I just
want to launch into some dialogue with
with the two of you and ask you some
questions which I hope will will inform
the audience and which I hope will give
us a us and myself and my team also
grist for the mill as it were I'd like
to say that some of my team are here not
all of them who've helped and Yale has
been truly the the home of the project
cooperation in 2020 and continuously
Yale forestry and the School of
Management have been the providers of
remarkable talent Yvonne and intend to
have written complete chapters in this
book and of course all chapters written
with passion tend to get edited by
people like me because you know I might
have slightly different styles and views
and so on but by and large this is the
work of a team and that's what you see
in corporation 2020 Patagonia has been a
leader in creating and building this DNA
and among the things that you've been
involved in is creating an understanding
of externalities if on ice and wind I
still remember this lovely sentence in
your book which I have quoted now very
often which is if the simplest statement
of the problem of externalities which
that everything manufactured you say
everything manufactured is sold at a
price which is lower than its cost and
that's the way of saying that of course
the externalities of the business are
not accounted for and the prices of the
resources that go in are not properly
priced resource taxation doesn't exist
which is a theme in our book and
externalities are a team in our book do
you see the the word externalities and
the idea of being cognizant of
externalities becoming something that
will come become real as a result of
things like your outdoor industry
association and the sustainable
Alysha do you see this as a direction
that's moving in the right way well I
think it'll be forced by the consumer
you know you'll affect change in
corporations either through government
regulation or through the market yeah
and by further you know the strongest
forces market force once consumers start
voting with their wallet their wallets
and once we can educate consumers so
that you walk into a department store
and there's five brands of jeans and and
each one has a grade according to how
responsibly they were made and one is
the two and one is the ten I really
believe that the consumer will make
intelligent choices based on the health
of the planet and choose the genes that
have caused the least amount of damage
you know most of the damage caused to
the environment is caused
unintentionally yeah just to ignorance
we have no idea you know I've heard that
it takes seven barrels and petroleum to
produce one cow well you know once once
you start thinking about that oh my god
we're supporting by eating meat we're
supporting the petroleum industry so
when it comes to consumer goods I think
we have a chance by changing by making
it you know what we're trying to do at
Patagonia is making it very uncool to
consume and discs are endlessly you know
a guy built a twenty five thousand
square foot home in Jackson Hole and he
was driven out of Jackson Hole because
his neighbors made so much fun of him
that he he left he didn't feel welcome
that's what we have to do and and now I
mean corporations only make what we want
what we tell them to make
you know we're not gonna affect
petroleum companies because we're
addicts you're not gonna tell your
pusher that you know gonna buy drugs
from them anymore so that's a different
story but when it comes to making
clothing or any kind of consumer goods
we could have a huge effect by how we
vote so I think it's a matter of
sustainability index bringing awareness
of how much really goes into products I
mean I I talked about I think I hate to
be repeating myself but I've talked to
so many groups here so I don't know who
I what I said to who don't worry it's
fine you can say we're talking about
we've calculated how many liters of
water and gallons of water goes into
making a t-shirt huge it's enormous
amount of water but you can't stop at
that you have to calculate well what
kind of water it's not just water I mean
you know there's a big difference
between bottled water right in tap water
well there's a big difference between
growing cotton in an area where it rains
or an area that's in a desert and you're
depleting an aquifer that's where the
water is millions of years old and is
not being replenished like the RLC or
something which is drying up because of
cotton farming or they've had to put in
a dam a reservoir which caused all the
damage and displaced people and all of
that just to be growing cotton
sowhat's ourselves at Patagonia
understand that it's not just water
anymore it makes a big difference where
we grow our cotton now we can choose to
grow it in a in a place that rains yeah
but until we know that we're just as
stupid as everybody else
we're just we're just blindly going
along in business without looking
at externalities yeah you've given us a
number of ideas which I just like to
push a little further
Yvonne yes are you want to comment can
you hear me with the sustainable apparel
coalition one of the things that all of
these companies face cost pressures and
they face the risk of consumer
abandonment if they're all afraid of bad
press not bad press anymore but a bad
notice through the internet so companies
are very defensive but one of the things
the sustainable apparel coalition does
is it allows people to it allows
companies to establish industry-wide
standards that are pre competitive so a
company that might be afraid to do
something good because they're the other
company won't do it and they'll be able
to undercut them on price it doesn't
come into play you're essentially doing
a form of Industry regulation that
levels the playing field so that's
that's really important in working with
corporations toward toward change
he wasn't Vincent let me just you raised
the number of points let me just pick a
few of them three or four and use that
to take our discussion forward you've
brought in the issue of consumers and I
agree with you finally there's no force
greater than the consumer that could
change but today's consumer is bombarded
with today's advertising and today's MNC
is funding the advertising that creates
the demand where basically you're
preying on human insecurities converting
them into once converting the ones into
memes needs into demand demand into
production there's a cycle which is been
going on for some time your ad was
remarkable because insist went boom this
was the 1i I saw in November last year
said don't buy this jacket and that was
on on the day when everyone flocks to
stores to buy saying because here's its
footprint you should try and use it and
if not surrender it and then replace it
so that's one kind of advertising and
then there's everything else
don't we need to change that to sort of
get the consumer to actually be able to
respond to well these are her conscience
you know the Millennium generation
doesn't believe in advertising it's not
working for them they see through it
they see this all lies and and they
don't watch television I mean the
intelligent ones are not watching
television and they're communicating
among themselves and you know social
media can destroy a company overnight
yeah word of mouth and this is the new
advertising I mean look at magazines I
get these fly fishing magazine it used
to be this stick now they're this stick
there's no more advertising and times
have changed and I think social media is
such a powerful force you know I talked
about civil democracy strongest force in
the world
I mean it creates government's it takes
down government's any gains we're making
as a society are being done through
civil democracy there's nothing
happening in government and that's a
powerful force yeah and I think that's
that's my only hope is that that does
happen that does happen yeah it won't
one person who would definitely agree
with you on the social media is Jochen
Zeitz the exec chairman of Puma he's
also very interested like yourselves in
moving forward towards disclosing X
manatees would he and his company and
others be part of the coalition they are
yeah we have we have almost 50 companies
which represent about 35% of the entire
apparel and footwear sales in the world
X represented and it's like you know
they're doing it because they don't want
to see water standards mm-hm
you know you see organic standards for
food and government you know fueled by
pressure from corporations is always
trying to dumb down those standards I'm
really convinced that these 50 companies
are doing this because they don't want
to see water standards and in fact most
of them have nothing to lose it's still
going to be a level playing field for
them you'd say take target for instance
they sell products from lots of other
manufacturers and you know by cleaning
up the whole supply chain of all of
these different manufactures it's gonna
be a level playing field for them they
don't care it's not gonna cost them any
money but is really driving change down
all through the supply chain I mean when
we announced this sustainability index
in China we invited a 250 big
manufacturers in the clothing business
thousands wanted to come and there was
250 went away saying I'm gonna get ahead
of this curve I'm gonna start doing it
right now I'm gonna clean up my act as
this is coming there's a powerful force
that's very good news then and it also
suggests that typically there is a lot
of competition and a sense of me first
and sometimes leaders like Puma may lead
in a direction leaders like Patagonia
may lead in that direction but others
will not follow because they got there
first they've taken the space so to
speak do you sense a bit of that or have
the leaders on business become more
mature I mean look look what happened in
our mobile industry in America by
dragging their feet waiting for the
customer to tell them what to do they
almost went bankrupt yeah they had to be
forced by the government to change and
guess what they're starting to thrive
now so the companies that will be
dragging their feet are gonna go out of
business because it's a different world
now Vincent do you see others following
the example of the
apparels coalition the sustainable
apparel coalition in terms of getting
together and creating product standards
and company-wide standards for
disclosure yeah I don't know a lot about
how robust or how serious the activity
is but I know there were over 400
different indexes being industry indexes
every every company every issue that we
see in our personal life or everything
that we care about as human beings
eventually comes across the corporate
table because these these corporations
which are structured very badly and -
and almost have to create harm are also
run by human beings who run into these
questions in their own lives and they
face actual corporate pressures that
they in terms of the cost of everything
we were just talking about the costs to
heat a home in Connecticut and you know
for a large house of four thousand
dollars a month or something like that
with with fuel oil and two thousand a
month of natural gas well this is
extraordinary and you can imagine what
kinds of pressures this creates for for
companies who are have to operate on a
much larger scale than the personal home
it gives us an idea and specifically let
me explore two avenues you brought up
the issue of cotton as coalition's such
as these evolve standards and hopefully
consistent standards would that create
in your opinion more pressure to grow
the right cotton to grow cotton in the
right way to use water in the more
responsible way I mean you you you have
a quite a challenge convincing cotton
growers to give you organic cotton at
the time when you decided to change you
had to go down to the village level and
the farm level yeah communicate what you
needed
hopefully will this change or is this
still a challenge to get resources no
it's not a challenge anymore I mean you
know when we decided to switch over to
organically grown cotton there was no
help out there from anyone there were no
books about how to make clothing more
responsible there was no books about
whether dyes are toxic or not there was
no information whatsoever there were
hardly anyone growing cotton organically
because a few companies like VF
Corporation and Esprit had tried it but
they tried it with an added
that well we'll try this and if it
doesn't work we can always go back and
sure enough it didn't work and they went
back well we said we're gonna not make
clothes if we have to use industrially
grown cotton because it's evil and that
made a real commitment but we had to
invent all of this stuff we had to we
had to co-sign loans for the farmer who
couldn't get a better loan from the bank
because the banks are in business with
the chemical company then and then you
know okay so then we finally figure out
some partnerships with a few suppliers
what the the the spinning mills wouldn't
spend our cotton into yarn
because it was sticky it's like bad you
know it was full of seeds and stems and
and sticky hey Fitz you know the sticky
stuff from aces and so no one would spin
our cotton so then we found one spinner
in Thailand who froze it and froze the
cotton and then it ran through the
machines okay he did it because he saw
that this was the future right right and
we worked with a few partners and now
you can buy organic cotton from all over
the place well many countries are
growing it a lot of spinners there it'll
spin it for you the cotton gins will
Genet for you and so we created this and
it's all people who believe that this is
the right right way forward yeah and it
can be both people who believe that
morally and also people who see a
business opportunity which are our
spinner in Thailand did did it for both
reasons we also worked 20 years ago to
we a supplier literally created a new
kind of recycled catalog paper
capable of printing high-quality
photographs for us knowing that he would
never make the money back from us but he
could sell it as a create a new product
in the industry and that's he did and
was very successful so that's another
were the first ones to do a catalog on a
recycled paper and now you pick up a
surfing magazine and it's recycled paper
and yeah it started from us we were the
first ones that to ask us paper
companies to do this yeah sometimes a
little leadership can go a long way good
ones and sometimes they can leave you
lonely when you get so far ahead of the
pack they shoot you in the back actually
I was recently in China with the head of
solar water heater makers the lab the
world's largest what's in it iemon oh
that doesn't actually his name is Wan
Ming so this was kind of the
Anglicization of one man but anyway he's
this thing about the Tigers he was
telling me that I was asking what is
your biggest threat he says my
competition wants to kill me I said
excuse me actually said my competition
wants to kill me they are talking to the
government with negative stories yeah
they are trying to eat into my my market
they're trying to change the laws which
will destroy my business this it is true
that leaders don't necessarily not only
not have followers sometimes they have
serious opponents but I for one I'm
delighted that that you stuck with it I
want to now ask a little more about this
whole issue of accounting because whilst
measuring externalities understanding
them is all part of responsible business
behavior and you've shown leadership
where you need to engage society a bit
more so that these ideas push down into
business practice more widely
we have great leaders such as yourself
we don't have enough followers and that
is the challenge of sustainability at an
economic matter
a worldwide economy level so how do we
get more followers and I think that's
what leads to let's see what systems can
be introduced which are in any case
being followed by the leaders but which
would be good for followers to follow a
question for you I mean yeah in your
book you both say accounting as practice
still assumes that the benefits of
nature and the Commons are free and that
spoiling them has no cost so how could
you give us some thoughts both of you on
what you would like to see change in the
nature of accounting such that the value
of nature such that the benefits which
business enjoys are reflected and the
damages are not caused in the way they
are well first of all we don't see as
our competition when when we make an
organic t-shirt we don't see that our
competition is a beefy T's because it's
a completely different product we see
our competition is other companies
making organic cotton t-shirts and the
more competition that we have in making
organic t-shirts the happier we are so
we're sharing because then it means that
the price goes down because you know
because of quantity and so we share all
this information with other companies
with competitors we started organic
cotton exchange that that if you're a
company that wants to do clothing out of
organic cotton you go to them and they
give you all the sources and suppliers
and you can go online at Patagonia
footprint chronicles and he'll tell you
where we make all our stuff I'll give
you the names of the factories why do we
do that because we want them to thrive
right with and when we asked them to
have a better labor practice or you know
you should have a child care center in
this factory they'll do it because they
want our business and is see they know
that it brings in other business anyway
I I think it would be difficult for us
as a as a company to develop accounting
practices that could then be used by
other companies we don't have that kind
of expertise and so but what we tend to
do when we're in that situation is to
work with partners or to learn from
other people sure so we mentioned in the
book there's a partnership now between
Dow Chemical and the Nature Conservancy
and PricewaterhouseCoopers to really
measure all of the external costs for
every product a chemical mix so that's a
very serious ambition if that removing a
pump I that's a if some comes if some
larger companies do that and if some
associations if the if the big
accounting firms start to develop that
methodology then I think that's
something we can adopt and it's also
something that we can help push within
our industry I'm gonna pick you up on
that one because we are actually doing
that
there's a quote another coalition that's
been formed consisting of the World
Business Council of the integral
international integrated reporting
committee GRI basically and supported by
the teeb group so a lot of ecological
and environmental economists and
technical engineers involved in actually
estimating the best analogies on a
sector-by-sector basis and I hope to be
following up very soon afterwards with
you at least for the apparel side
because we want one of our one of our
projects is on cement another is as in
the US with SAS peer on health industry
and the other should be on hopefully
apparent so with with that kind of if
you like external support and of course
this includes the accountancy firms as
well so with that kind of external
support do you feel comfortable moving
forward in this direction yeah we I
don't I'm not the CFO but
so I shouldn't speak for her but I think
that that's that's exactly the kind of
thing we would tend to take up but we've
mentioned that we we pay 1% for the for
the planet we give 1% of our sales
rather than a percentage of profits to
environmental causes and we tax
ourselves but we really don't know the
environmental cost financially and so
you know we would equally welcome we
also had a we were talking about at
lunch about kind of the role of the the
intersection between the University and
the corporation and in any way and I
think one of the things we've
experienced we our company grew out of a
very small culture of climbers and
surfers that we hired friends of friends
and we were able to keep this fairly
horizontal fairly passionate
environmentally oriented culture of
people who love nature we got it to
survive from two sales of 200,000 a year
to 600 million a year forty years later
but we've also grafted on a professional
culture and not just one professional
culture but several because the people
who do work in our in finance and do
have MBAs the people who work in our
production come from you know the
University of North Carolina textile
Department people from marketing have
marketing degrees and then they've come
to us through various company cultures
none of them have ever had any kind of
education and sustainable practices or
in valuing externalities so they come
into the company with this kind of
training and we have to kind of graft
the Patagonia experience it would be a
tremendous benefit to any company that
was trying to do something to have the
kinds of questions that are raised in
this school as part of the professional
background of almost everybody who'd
come in
to work in a corporation no I completely
agree and I think that's that's
something certainly that I'm personally
committed to together with the people
from this teeth external business
externalities coalition my final
question to both of you is really where
next you Patagonia clearly has the
social purpose behind that you
recognized early as you've said the
needs of the planet and the needs of
society and built that into your
business model that's actually the
number one principle that we have in
cooperation 2020 you just mentioned wins
in the toko
and your your use of the word culture is
exactly the words that we use as well
the creation of culture the adoption of
culture and turning that into community
and that itself generating that
collection of forces between people that
make things work today the village
community and the neighborhood are dying
away but corporations have the
opportunity because of who they are and
how powerful an institution they are to
create alternative good communities and
you're clearly doing that you teach
people you come in and create knowledge
in them increase their capacity to earn
you create human capital the Institute
aspect of the problem of the corporation
again you bang on and finally and to me
most importantly understanding
externalities understanding that the
space in which the corporation operates
today is not just a space of physical
and financial capital for shareholders
but rather the space of physical
financial human social and especially
natural capital for stakeholders widely
and responding to that understanding
behaving as if you are truly optimizing
value other than just optimizing share
of the profits I think Patagonia takes
all those boxes so in that sense the way
we define that you would be a
corporation 2020 my challenge and my
question is where next how do we get
more companies to be like you what are
the key levers that you would pull what
are the key things that you would do
well
I mean I'm not an educator I only know
what I can do with my own company and
I've always believed that there's only
one form of leadership that's by example
so what we're trying to do is minimize
the damage that we do as a company and
educate our customers lead by example
hopefully and by doing that have other
companies see that this is a profitable
business model in fact every time I have
a business problem the answer has always
increased the quality and I see that as
as the way out of this consuming
discarding endlessly Society is to buy
fewer products but very much higher
quality products that are
multifunctional they'll last a long time
and and something that you can prize and
give to your children and I mean that's
the kind of society we have to get to we
have to get away from this consume
discard because it's you know we have
limits economists won't admit it but
there are limits to everything that
humans do yeah that all planetary
boundaries I think absolutely and we're
we've gone beyond those limits in fact
we're killing ourselves we're destroying
the planet that is the source of
everything we need and depend on and so
but when I look at my company I mean
back back to being on the cover of
Fortune magazine and it said the coolest
company on the planet my Italian friend
who has a wry sense of humor wrote wrote
to me and said oh I see you're on the
cover of Fortune said I see that the
mouse got the advertising cat magazine
well I think we are influencing okay
throw their companies and that's why we
stay in business I mean I have no desire
to become wealthier and I don't have any
desire to see Patagonia get to be a
billion dollar company it may become a
billion dollar company and in fact it's
that we have more recession it's
probably will because we just thrive in
recessions because yeah consumers become
conservative they stop being silly they
stopped buying fashion they buy
practical products and that's what we
make and it's go away less yeah but I
constantly you know being a climber and
a kayaker and doing a lot of different
risks sports in my life I know that
there you never exceed your resources
and live within your means otherwise
you're dead and so I'm constantly trying
to think about what size Patagonia
should be not that we want to stop at
that size but we want to keep strictly
with natural growth not growth that's
fueled by more advertising and more
promotion and more building more stores
or anything but growth that's fueled by
a natural demand for our products right
and I don't know what that is but we
have no desire to exceed that and I
think you know we're all amateurs
Patagonia I mean there's very few people
with a business degree I have a degree
in John Burroughs high school an auto
mechanic that's good so I think we need
to diversify the company and I'm
interested in the food business because
I I'm such a pessimist that I think one
world event could bring the whole world
economy down because its global now and
you know nature hates
gigantism it hates globalism it wants to
constantly make new species and it loves
small diverse things yeah and you know
the more global you are the more at risk
you are of the business and I want to
diversify the company and I'm very
interested in food because the
revolution that we've hopefully started
with clothing I want to do with food
fantastic because we're not going to
need clothing in the tough times we're
gonna need to eat and we're gonna eat
need to eat in a different way than
we're eating now Yvonne and Vincent
that's wonderful thank you very much
with that sobering and exciting sobering
because it's about coming back to basics
food exciting because it suddenly gives
me an idea of what to call you here next
for which is the food industry so bring
an exciting force I'd like to give the
floor us to to the audience but first
I'd like a special mention and welcome
to Allen white Allen thank you for being
an inspiration and thank you for
inventing the original corporation 2020
which was 20/20 division a very
thoughtful project and initiative about
corporately design whose straight
threads and strings we picked up and
tried to see what can we do quickly as
in by the year 2020 when we believe that
we are hitting planetary boundaries to a
point where I think if we haven't
changed economic direction and resource
use then that's curtains and that's the
reason why I'm here you're a doom that
is but I just want to first stir the
conversation with the audience island by
requesting you to just give a few
comments and do you think we are on the
right track from where you began more
than a decade ago a couple of decades
ago actually you think about it and I'll
be on the right track and what do you
make of Patagonia as as an example of
corporation very exciting the second
one's easy
you're my hero
they have indeed without thinking about
the big intellectual ideas and long
visions and necessarily but just by way
of example the leadership by example is
all about is what Patagonia is about so
the inspiration even the mainstreaming
with your face on Fortune magazine I
mean that's that's the ultimate
intrusion I would say into the world of
business and particularly large business
so I congratulate you and I and onward
I'll buy your food as well along with
LaVon and I say to pavan that we as we
coined the term corporation 2020 some
eight years ago with a focus on what we
call corporate purpose corporate design
corporate ownership structures and
corporate governance those were our
themes and we were from that time
painting pictures of the since that time
been painting pictures of future forms
of the corporation imagining what they
would look like in 2020 and beyond 2030
even and trying to imagine not just the
models of the future but pathways toward
them happily and fortunately and the
life Liat belong picked up the threads
for actions through accountable
advertising through resource taxation
through externalities disclosure and
sorry I'm missing whatever ace yeah
controlling leverage in business not
just financial corporations but
corporations generally which is a huge
problem of course creating the kind of
brittleness and potentially catastrophic
consequences that you've referred to in
this panel so the complementarity of our
building the vision our thinking about
these structures and models of the
future inspired by the real world people
like Patagonia people in other not to
arrive in Brazil there's small numbers
of companies that are not waiting for
the vision they are the vision in a way
novo nordisk in Denmark another sterling
example of a really creative thinking
pharmaceutical company John Lewis
Partnership in the UK
the deesser company Nike the poster
child of poor practices now come along
and very much listen deciding to look
and feel like Patagonia in a way in
terms of disclosure and sustainability
modeling for its products and indexing
and so on and so forth so that there's
there's numbers of these companies the
problem is the numbers are about to two
or three dozen in a my in our estimate
so companies are the go-to companies
those are the inspirations those are the
models that need to be scaled up by
thousands after all there's 80 hundred
thousand multinationals in the world and
untold millions of other enterprises so
it's a huge universe which is basically
detached from disjoined from all the
concepts the ideas that Pavan has been
developing that we've been developing in
our own modeling of corporate forms and
the it's it's it's a sload it's a
painfully slow journey but it's one that
we have to pursue if we don't pursue it
we're imperiling our future is clearly
already imperiling a future of each of
our grandchildren and that's simply not
an option so we have to get all these
wonderful ideas mainstreamed and we have
to do it quickly Thanks
questions from the audience
and so please and then after that lady a
quick question your name please
oh my name is Dylan Walsh I'm a graduate
of forestry school and you're moving
into the food sector sort of implies to
me that you don't see companies in the
food sector doing what you would like to
see done sort of stepping out and the
way you did in the apparel industry
three or four decades ago and I was
wondering if that's the case and if it's
not the case if you do see companies and
other sectors that and maybe 10 or 15
years might be the sort of next
generation Patagonia of their sector
well I'm looking at it more as an
entrepreneur you know I see we developed
a lot of very loyal customers who really
see the added value of all the things
that we're doing to be to cause less
harm and they're supporting us and I see
that there's a lot of confusion in food
you can go to a fish market and there's
organic Irish salmon what does that mean
it means in reality it means it's farmed
just like every other farm salmon in net
pens out in the ocean and there's you
know it's just much jelly see lights
underneath the pen and then down below
the pendous in the ground is six seven
feet of fecal matter and where there's
nothing alive wherever they put a fish
farm in an estuary it kills all the
lobster fishing I mean it it's horrible
but you go to a fish market it's called
organic Irish salmon host sounds good
think I'll buy that you know most of the
so-called energy bars that you see are
candy bars
you know yeah there's no cane sugar
there's no high fructose corn syrup but
there's sugar made from rice you know
they're candy bar I can't eat them
because I don't like heavy sweet foods
like that so there's a lot of confusion
yeah there are you go to a health food
store and there's a bazillion products
in there all touting to be good for you
what does that mean are they really good
for you I mean look how many people have
allergies to gluten does one out of
three people born in America is going to
have diabetes we're eating wrong and yet
this health
stores all over the place so I want to I
want to you know have a clear message I
want every product that we do is going
to be well thought out as sustainable
and made as responsibly as possible so
that the Patagonia customers just buys
the Patagonia provisions product without
having to read his monstrous labels to
see if there's anything toxic in there
or not right
so I look at it as an entrepreneur just
like I looked at clothing I mean we
didn't start out to make responsible
clothing we couldn't make any money
hammering out PETA's and my blacksmith
shop so I saw it as an opportunity to
make money thanks for that lady I am
Anastasia Arak I'm also a I do it at
this school and an entrepreneur and I'm
working on exactly on this problem of
proliferation of labels and standards
and so on so my question to you is how
do you actually decide as a company
which type of standard you get involved
in so I see that you have blue sign and
you're involved in the sustainable
apparel coalition which is so quasi
standard but there are many more out
there so which ones do you actually put
resources into given that you're a
leader and probably in many cases ahead
of what the standards are going to be
end up being set up
Thanks yeah we look at who we think is
the most serious and also the most
practical and results-oriented so we
like the blue side people a lot we help
get them we also help get them started
it's a Swiss Swiss firm they evaluate
the processes as well as the chemical
elements and every dye in Finnish used
in fabric we couldn't do this on on our
own we couldn't develop that expertise
on our own so we I'm not even there are
there I wasn't part of the process that
chose blue sign over others but I know
we helped kind of know
them along the way that we thought was
the best we work with Fair Labor
Association to do social audits or
audits and factories they were started
by a fellow who was South African who
was involved in the anti-apartheid
movement and then got involved in the
anti child labor movement they work with
a number of companies they work
proactively rather than giving a company
report card they help companies
establish mediation procedures for
problems so you know it's a case-by-case
basis but we you generally have two or
three for institutions or groups to
choose from and we choose the ones we
think are the most serious and also
practical and also sometimes fast-moving
because some of that some of the
organizations that come out of academic
work can be very very slow lady in the
front and the gentleman in the green
jacket in the back hi I'm Melissa spear
also a graduate of the School of
Forestry and I run an organization here
in New Haven which is focused on working
with urban youth in developing ecologic
illiteracy in urban youth I'm in and one
of the key points well there are two
points to develop the next generation
environmental leaders but also to get
them to understand what the impact of
their consumer choices are and I I feel
that urban youth in particular from and
many from low-income neighborhoods are a
really key part of the consumer base and
I'm wondering if your company has
thought about what role they play in
your constituency and how you reach out
to them because I certainly think it's
critical to this movement that they
embrace the same principles that that we
do well we can't do it all so we're
focused on seeing that there's a
habitable planet
that's about I mean you know we'd give
five five and a half million dollars
away last year we gave two 600 700
different environmental organizations we
can't give to every single one that hits
us up
so we've limited ourselves strictly to
activists environmental organizations
and we don't give to the big ones
because you know Nature Conservancy gets
its money from conservatives so we give
money to the little grassroots
organizations that no one else will fund
excellent and so as far as this social
aspect the food will have a social
aspect in each case you know like I've
been interested in grains and one of the
grains I was really interested in is
barley and because I've done a lot of
climbing in the Himalayas and Tibet
places and I've talked to Sherpas who
say yeah we'll eat your freeze-dried
food down low but up high we need to eat
our barley and butter tea because that
gives us energy well why does this
roasted barley give them more energy
than our freeze-dried dinners I want to
know the answer to that and so maybe we
come out with a Samba a barley Samba
that you can use for backpacking you can
use in your house and there's a story of
of why it's the key ingredient in
Tibetan foods and like right now I'm
looking to do bison jerky we're gonna be
but buying the bison locally and from
I'm from South Dakota and and we're
trying to convince the Lakota Sioux to
get rid of their cows and switch to
bison and we'll buy their bison if they
do that so each food will have a social
aspect to it but but anyway we can't do
it all
we're just trying to save this planet
because like David Brower says there's
no business to be done on our planet
very well and the last question and
after that I'll request the train to
come back in here and receive his books
my name is Ravi
vulnera I'm a student in Yale freshman
in Yale College and you talk about this
a lot yesterday and at the law school a
little bit today and it seems that one
of the one of the main reasons that
Patagonia has been able to be so
successful in promoting social
entrepreneurship and promoting companies
that actually do good and are successful
companies is because obviously Patagonia
has been a very successful company as a
business and so I guess my question is
is how do you balance the need to be a
successful business and obviously make a
profit and and survive in the market and
and also continue to kind of do this
good and make that an absolute priority
so I guess this question really is about
growth and how far do you see the need
to grow Patagonia as a business in order
to actually continue to really do good
well I want to stay being the mouse I
think
we're not focused on profits have you
asked me how much we made last year I
have no idea I couldn't care less or
what how much we're gonna make this year
I'm the real Zen Buddhist about this
whole thing I know that the process of
the business is going right there for
the profits are going to happen so we
don't worry about being a profitable
company we don't worry about growth we
don't worry about all those things that
a normal company worries about like for
instance we put in a childcare center
on-site childcare center when there's
only 50 in the whole United States
corporate childcare centers our
accountants were saying oh my god this
is gonna cost you a fortune you know
it's gonna hurt the bottom line but we
don't care about things like that we
just knew that it was the right thing to
do and in fact the best product comes
out of Patagonia is those kids out of
childcare including my own kids that
came out of there those kids are brought
up by the village they're not brought up
by a woman who was fired because she was
pregnant and then has to raise single
child at home and plug them into the
television all day long these kids are
brought up by the entire village and you
can't believe the quality of the those
children they you go in there I went in
there one day and I said hi kids how
school one little kid we're not in
school we're at work our parents work
over there I work here
and they stick their hand out and shake
hands with you instead of hiding behind
their mother's skirt yeah that's right
it's incredible and yet if you listen to
the accounts they'll tell you you can't
do that
there was also when we introduced take
care and I was one of the ones opposed
to this oh I thought you said you were
in day care what happened actually
happened is that it really did increase
the employee loyalty would it made
people work harder for the company and
work smarter for the company but it also
really made a difference in the culture
it really makes a difference to have
kids on site and it reduces a comment
last night is very hard to act
vice-presidential around a toddler and
it increases the level of kind of
horizontal Kim and human concern that
people have for each other rather than
start to play active to the roles of
hierarchy the other thing I think is
that we it is very easy to be a kind of
a corporation 19:24 hacia in terms of
worrying about profit and sort of living
within our means and walking away with a
few more pennies at the end of the day
that we then reinvest it's not so hard
to run our business that way what would
be impossible for us is if we were I
think if we were trying to act like a
Silicon Valley startup if we were
intended to sell the company very
shortly and we were building we were
bulking it up for sale lowering quality
trying to drive down the cost that would
really spoil the company and I don't
think we could I don't think we could
operate within our values of do that so
the kind of traditional model of earn a
profit every year we're finding that but
the the newer model of build up a
company make a killing retire and move
to Rarotonga
we can't do that well thank you very
much indeed to vincent anybody thank you